the metaphor of oneness is useful to
explain how all things near and far from
each other are ultimately connected to
each other and ultimately influence each
other the failure to recognize the
interconnectedness of all things and
people people with what we call nature
animals with what we call people is
certainly one of the problems the
conditional recognition that we are not
the same person is a healthy
precondition for my gaining a greater
understanding of the universe by
listening to you carefully one has to
acknowledge that you know sometimes a
very highly educated people people who
are very thoughtful very careful they
check their data they check their
syllogisms they ask the criticism and
they work really hard to get things
right sometimes they get it wrong too
but that doesn't mean that people just
based upon their instinct or their gut
and their dismissal of those who analyze
carefully would be making better
decisions let's see the foundation of it
is that I study religions of African
inspirations around the Atlantic
perimeter West African Yoruba religion
West Central African Congo religion
Brazilian Khandala Haitian Vodou Cuban
scented and Cuban Santiago orchha I
think I got all of them ok and ever
since about 1981 I've been researching
and my major mode of study is to read as
much as I can but then to go out and
hang out deeply with people to live with
people eat what they eat dance what they
dance worship what they worship let's
think about the world in their terms by
living that life that's the fundamental
share technique of socio-cultural
anthropology I am I'm a person of both
worlds on the person of Afro Atlantic
religions I'm a person of the Western
Academy
I'm an anthropologist trying to
understand the web of relationships that
people create through these objects and
I'm trying my best to learn how
Africanist art historians understand
them as well but you know the ability to
describe the differences among colors to
notice the textures to examine the
historical precedence in Wroclaw clothes
style as opposed to neoclassical style
each of these traditions makes a
somewhat different set of assumptions
about the world a somewhat different set
of assumptions about what kind of
objects best embody the forces that
penetrate us and overlap within us and
each of them is structured by a
different kind of Mythology someone's
opinion me contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we and what is the
nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don Sakia we are on-site at the
American Anthropological Association
annual meeting for our second
partnership with them now in vancouver
british columbia we are now going to be
sitting with dr. jay LaRonde matauri AKA
randy hi Randy all right
I'm very excited for our conversation
Randy is a Lawrence Richardson professor
of cultural anthropology at Duke also
director of the sacred arts of the black
Atlantic project at Duke and we'll be
diving into those two subjects before we
start I want to ask you some of our very
deep questions that we've been obsessed
with recently are we really all one
to me oneness is a metaphor I believe
that all of the substances beings and
things around us are connected with each
other and that our tendency to give each
of them a noun is really only
approximate reality each thing is a halo
it's a halo of atoms and in culture
specific and in language specific ways
we artificially presuppose the
boundedness of each of those things
the conceptual boundedness and the
physical boundedness of those things but
again all of these things are halos
things interdigitate with each other
things depend on each other
this table couldn't sit where it is were
it not for this floor you and I couldn't
sit here were it not for this floor the
thoughts that I'm articulating are now
part of your thoughts and the visual
impression of you is part of my thoughts
nothing in us so many things in us would
be very different we're not looking at
you and many things and you would be
different synaptically were you not
listening to me so the metaphor of
oneness is useful to explain how all
things near and far from each other are
ultimately connected to each other and
ultimately influence each other but I
don't think it's a fiction for me to
call you Allan and for you to call me
Randy insofar as we are conditionally
separate halos we are conditionally
separate clouds of atoms whose contents
don't thoroughly overlap but it's very
useful for us to recognize that already
after three days of acquaintances there
is not an insignificant overlap between
who you are and who I am already and
then given this deep level of
interconnectedness to each other to
nature to all of existence would this
then be the most upstream
shoo our lack of acknowledgement of that
deep interconnectedness that is then
causing all the downstream issues that
our society faces the failure to
recognize the interconnectedness of all
things and people people with what we
call nature animals with what we call
people is certainly one of the problems
the exaggerated premise of individuality
in the West the exaggerated premise of
the uniqueness of human beings and our
rights the exaggerated premise of the
uniqueness of the rights of Westerners
or Europeans or men or straight people
lend themselves to a good deal of unkind
treatment of others which result in a
degrading effects to the world that we
need to share on the other hand my
appreciation of you is partly related to
the fact that your bundle of molecules
has had different experiences from my
bundle of molecules you look different
you grew up speaking a set of languages
that's different from the set of
languages that I grew up speaking you
you are looking to that direction and
I'm looking at this direction so to my
mind the conditional recognition that we
are not the same person is a healthy
precondition for my gaining a greater
understanding of the universe by
listening to you carefully my delighting
and a new kind of human connection
because you are not exactly like some
people I grew up with or not exactly
like my wife or child or not exactly
like my colleague my acknowledging the
difference between you and all of them
is a precursor to my appreciating you
fully and learning as much as I can from
you
given the amount of wisdom and
intelligence that comes with the
awareness of the behaviors and the
insights of indigenous people around our
world and then the younger brother out
in the metropolis is that is creating
engineering tinkering making things that
are useful at times would it be a happy
marriage between these two this
indigenous intelligence with some of the
abilities of modernity for there to be a
better path moving forward mm-hmm yes I
assume that richer and more sincere
conversations across all social
categories will make the world a better
place I'm not sure that I know enough
people who define themselves as
indigenous to generalize about what they
have to contribute I certainly know a
lot of people who understand themselves
to be modern which which category I
think includes a wide diversity of
people I consider myself to be a modern
person I tend to think of you as a
modern person both of whom have sampled
a range of ways of thinking and are
trying to find our way to the best ones
I'm a bit hesitant to credit a whole
population of people called indigenous
with with a greater wisdom because
concretely and honestly speaking I am
aware of more than a few Native
Americans who who disregard the rights
of the African decended people who are
members of their nations so for example
the the Seminoles and the Cherokees have
since the 1980s voted about a dozen
times to exclude their African descended
citizens from rights of citizenship that
is to say these tribes like several
other
in the southeast owned african people
and when Andrew Jackson displaced these
populations from the southeast giving
them parts of Oklahoma they're enslaved
people went with them and often helped
to mediate relations with white us
Americans so as to get the best deals
for these tribes and yet these tribes
have repeatedly voted to disenfranchise
the descendants of Africans so if we
consider these populations indigenous I
would also consider that that indigenous
people are equally vulnerable to the
sorts of inhumanity kindness and out of
proportion thinking that that modern
populations are capable of yeah this is
really important example to bring up and
and I appreciate you doing so that's
very helpful this complexity of this
reality that we find ourselves in is
this the purpose of this all being here
of this reality being here is us
figuring out how to harmonize our
reality and direct us in a more positive
flourishing direction well I take the
word purpose to be metaphorical to the
way that I think the universe doesn't
have purposes I don't think of the
universe as a human-like being that has
intentions or strategies to get toward a
particular goal I think things happen
some things make it much more likely
that other things will happen
and each living being can make choices
in a sense I mean the most obvious way
in which one has choices is based upon
analogy to human thinking so for example
I had the choice to come and participate
this interview or not you had the choice
to ask a quest one question or another
to ask it one way or another to hold
your silence when I gave a response or
to interrupt me we do things like that
all the time that that do reverberate
they have consequences afterwards that
we hope will be consistent with our
intentions and the purposes that we had
in mind when we chose to do thing X as
opposed to thing Y or to do X in one way
rather than another way of course we
know that our intentions and our
purposes don't always predictably lead
to the objectives that were pursuing
sometimes we accidentally did it the
wrong way or the other person received
it the wrong way so the outcome is not
what we intended so there's only a
certain degree to which the purpose even
of human beings of highly thoughtful
well planned Planning individuals can be
described as purposive in the sense of
really achieving that end each of us
when we choose a way of doing things is
also being affected by the state of our
bodies whether we're feeling sick or or
healthy drunk or not drunk
whether we're seeing clearly or not what
assumptions were making what demons
trouble us all sorts of irrational stuff
intervenes in our decision-making such
that even when consciously we're trying
to be purposive there's a lot more going
on in shaping our behavior than the
purposes or than the intentional the
universe likewise you know I there are
some social theorists who emphasize or
claim that objects have agency as well
the fact that you know even though this
table is made up of a halo of molecules
electrons atoms nuclei it's really hard
for me to if I want to lower my arm to
this level it would be really hard for
me is simply to pass through the table
there's a small probability that I could
that you know my arm would go right
straight through the table there's a
small
probability given the way that atoms and
molecules were but it's very unlikely
and I chances are I would have to push
extremely hard to move my arm low
without going around the table so on
that grounds
some argue that tables have agency
this building has agency in a sense that
it's cooling the room in a certain way
and enabling us to talk without the
effects that he would have on us but it
is having the effects that being a
little too cold is having on me that
shape and how I talk that shape and how
I move that shaping how well I'm able to
think but I think there were some living
thinking beings who more or less made
some choices that caused the building to
do this it's hard for me to see to
attribute to the building agency even
though I know that whatever button the
engineer pushed the building might do
something different whatever the
building was expected to do when the
button was pushed might be shaped by
geological and atmospheric electrical
forces that make it do something
different and so all of that
interconnection of things those those
events that intervene between our
intention and the outcomes that we
generate those are powerful forces I
don't necessarily call them intentions
or purposes I don't have exactly the
vocabulary for that but the universe is
full of stuff like that whether there's
a single ultimate purpose I don't know
but I do believe it's fair for human
beings like you and me to assign to rank
our goals for example if it is your goal
to help us all to behave with a
recognition that our harm to one of us
is a harm to all of us or a harm to him
is also a harm to me that is a perfectly
laudable human purpose and one of the
messages of oneness to me might be that
each of us must show a degree of
humility
with regard to the fact that no matter
what our intentions are and how well
we've thought them out including the
intention to encourage oneness we must
constantly pay attention to the
consequences on the other some utopian
dreams of oneness that had been pursued
to dogmatically whether it's Stalinist
socialism or Pol Pot's
socialism or or Mussolini and and and
Hitler's fascism some such pursuits of
oneness that then dogmatically failed to
check back in on whether the harm done
to many sufficiently justifies the
expectation of of comfort once we are
whole it's a good reminder that the one
does not answer or serve the same
purpose as our utopian dreams of oneness
sometimes it manifests realities that
are beyond what we could think of when
we named the one another purpose of
pursuit of oneness was eugenics the
premise that all of society would be
improved if we sterilized certain people
whom the Genesis the whole list thinker
thought weren't contributing to the
whole properly or were diminishing the
whole and they actually sterilized
people with the premise that the whole
was more important than those people and
so I would urge that the pursuit of the
one the practical philosophy and premise
that we are one interpreted according to
a certain set of expectations about how
we treat each other
even articulated by the wisest person
should be accompanied by a certain
humility by that person about what
oneness should really mean yeah yeah and
those that seek to build that next world
of the one carrying humility in the
process and enabling really deep
discourse around morals ethics
philosophies architectures designs for
maximum flourishing is paramount I agree
yeah and thought is really important
they're these people who think that just
because they Intuit something they can
go for it like the Donald Trump
philosophy he doesn't believe that he
has to pay attention to people who
analyze things carefully who's been
years and years trying to figure out
something with the humility that they're
not always right but they're trying to
gather as many perspectives as possible
and double-check their inferences very
carefully there are some people and a
large part of the US American population
who like Donald Trump thinks oh well if
a claim feels right for me then it's the
truth
and they'll look at the mistakes that
highly educated people and journalists
who are trying to be careful sometimes
make and they'll say you see how those
educated people got it wrong those
people who analyze things down to the
nth degree you see how they said they
get it wrong and they're willing to leap
from there to the conclusion that if you
analyze things very carefully and with
self scrutiny you're just as likely to
get it wrong as if you go on your gut
and most of the people who say that are
not very highly educated one has to
acknowledge that you know sometimes very
highly educated people people who are
very thoughtful very careful they check
their data they check their syllogisms
they ask for criticism and they work
really hard to get things right
sometimes they get it wrong too but that
doesn't mean that people just based upon
their in
where their gut and their dismissal of
those who analyze carefully would be
making better decisions in fact
regularly people dismiss facts refuse to
double-check their syllogisms and refuse
to listen to criticism because from the
very start they wanted to do something
unkind to somebody else and they want to
get away with it and not be scrutinized
for it
so in other words I'm affirming yes
humility
careful thought careful investigation
are a much better way to improve the
world than these people who refuse
careful thought because they think their
gut is just as good yeah it's a also
another one of these feels like a
marriage of rationality with intuition
yeah when you can merge both of those
together I want to pass some time on the
focus of yours on the sacred arts of the
black Atlantic project yeah this is
beautiful I saw your handout that you
were delivering and the talk that you
were delivering today you came to my
talk well I was able to listen to it
because of reading over the talk yeah
yesterday
oh yes didn't actually attend that was
the doing another interview oh I
understand yeah it changed a lot it was
only my teach don't what yeah cuz you
know I rethink things I'm never
satisfied with the last version i
rethought it that cut stuff I added
stuff and I don't think it was filmed
but that's another thing that triple
ache I was hoping to pass along to them
this I would love for the talks to begin
do you think filmed and then put up on
the Tripoli's YouTube and that type of I
mean I'll be passing along to their team
tomorrow in a small meeting so the but
to talk around the the sacred arts of
the black Atlantic project yeah all of
this the story that you have of going
out and making these beautiful
connections with different priests and
then being able to share with other
students these incredible artifacts that
tell stories and awaken people take this
his path okay well the UH let's see the
foundation of it is that I study
religions of African inspiration around
the Atlantic perimeter West African
Yoruba religion West Central African
Congo religion Brazilian condom Blair
Haitian voodoo Cuban Santa and Cuban
Santeria orchha I think I got all of
them okay and ever since about 1981
I've been researching trying to figure
out and writing about these traditions
coming up on 40 years that's right yeah
that's right
and my major mode of study is to read as
much as I can but then to go out and
hang out deeply with people to live with
people eat what they eat dance what they
dance worship what they worship you know
let's think about the world in their
terms by living that life that's the
fundamental share technique of
socio-cultural anthropology there are a
few of us who will just sit in a library
and analyze a book a few of us who will
examine lives online and think we're
painting a world but most of us value
the idea that the foremost learning
happens when we're hanging out with
people yeah not just interviewing them
but you know whatever comes up you learn
from the deepest experiential levels
exactly and listening to the stuff that
people say in the middle of a fight when
they're not you know when they're not
you know sort of programming a self
representation for the world to see or
when they don't feel they're being
surveilled how they act spontaneously
how they under what they take for
granted about the shape of the world and
the nature of people that's what we most
want to get at whether we're studying
religion or the economics of our society
the political aspects of that society
their kinship or what happened I want to
understand what they're taking for
granted and how for historical and
learned reasons it differs from what
other people are taking for granted
about the world
and so the understanding of how the
practitioners of spirit possession
religions and people who consecrate
objects turning them into gods think has
been profoundly transformative to me as
someone who grew up middle class in u.s.
American society who regarded things as
just technological instruments or tools
of our will and who grew up regarding
himself as an individual without any
fundamental and undeniable obligation to
anybody and with the thought that nobody
had any fundamental and undeniable
obligation to me either
independence was regarded as a virtue
so in encountering afro Atlantic priests
I had experiences like this my best
friend in Brazil witnessing me sewing a
button
that had popped off a shirt of mine back
in 1987 during my first Brazilian field
research and he said he looked at me put
his hands on his hips and said was they
at El Alto suficiente you're so
self-sufficient and it was not intended
as praise it was a criticism
so these traditions so assumed the
interconnectedness of people and our
interdigitating with forces of the
universe that the ideal of personal
autonomy and self-sufficiency that the
products of the Enlightenment that are
of the u.s. American middle class are
perceived as odd as they can understand
why we're the ones destroying the
universe they can understand why we have
very high suicide rates this is how our
world is seen by them wow this really
loops us back to the oneness again yeah
yeah Wow
and so you know I'm still the post
enlightenment Western middle class me
the child of privilege I mean I love
owning beautiful things I love living in
a comfortable house I love having my own
and enough money in the bank so that I
don't need to depend on as many people
as a poor person would on the other hand
I am also aware of fully able to
understand and grasp and internalize how
the being that is me interdigitate swith
the being that is the river the being
that as me interdigitate swith the being
that is the mountain the being that as
me interdigitate swith the being that is
you the being that is me interdigitate
swith and depends on the being that this
is built that is this building I can I
can think that way to and I can feel it
yeah and one of the sources and
embodiments of that feeling are the
sacred the consecrated objects and
embodied gods that have been given to me
by the priests of haitian vodou a
Brazilian condom Blair of West African
Yoruba religion and Cubans and didya and
I have developed a collection of sacred
arts that I began collecting back in
1982 at my first trip during my first
trip to Nigeria beautiful objects that
embody the spirit and the thinking and
the taking Takens for granted of people
in these religious traditions and over
the last maybe 15 or so years I have
been acquiring God's the priests who
have worked with me even though I'm not
fully initiated have come to believe
that I would benefit from and I would
take good care of gods that they have
made for me and I have done so they give
them to me and I take very very good
care of them the ones that like candles
and perfume I like candles for and give
perfume on a daily or almost daily basis
to the goddess of the river will be
whose name is Yemanja I light her candle
virtually every day I mean her Bell oh
and the Haitian gods I salute the way
they like with the rattles that
correspond to their service and usually
that rattle called Vyasa belongs to the
highest rank of initia in the tradition
of haitian vodou but the priestess
regarded me as fit to receive it so I
salute the gods as they wish to be
saluted and you follow these rituals
their sacred their most sacred practices
that then connect you to the deepest
roots of who they are and what they
especially know with the inter digitated
it's all yeah and each of these
traditions conceives of what we're
interdigitated with slightly differently
but I'm trying my best to learn from
each form of interdigitating and I take
it very seriously I have not done the
most sacred things and that is undergone
full initiation because the
Enlightenment self and me and this I'm a
third child to find subordination very
difficult it's not easy for me to
absolutely submit in ways that are
required by the fullest initiation but
but I am very conscientiously attentive
to the needs of these gods I with regard
to religious matters I obey the priests
if they you know Express subtle hints
they said well maybe you know maybe you
shouldn't do it that way or they laugh
at me what I do in a certain way like I
was you know one time the last time my
priestess friend from Haitian voodoo was
leading a sacred ceremony on behalf of
my gods for a large group of people I in
the matter of participant observation of
anthropology I went and got my [ __ ]
and as she shook tassel saluting the
gods and leaving the ceremony I would
shake mine in exactly the same way but
then she she said in my in my she said
to the other priests who were you know
performing the ritual with us after the
first part of it or the second part
ended she she said a mightily applause
so maturity has taken us off and she was
laughing I made that I think
why wait you're doing something that's
beyond your rank you shouldn't be doing
that
so I said off and so I took me him so I
put my ass on down but yes so I'm I am
I'm a person of both world so I'm a
person of Afro Atlantic religions I'm a
person of the Western Academy and end of
the Western middle class and and so what
you brought up was the sacred art I that
would be the prime rubric for an art
historian but I'm too humble to take on
the title of expert on African art per
se because they're people who do this
with such such excellence I'm an
anthropologist trying to understand the
web of relationships that people create
through these objects and I'm trying my
best to learn how africanist art
historians understand them as well I
admire what they do but sometimes they
look back at me and they say no you're
doing the right thing we want to do what
you're doing
but they don't realize how much they
know and how much I would like to grasp
like you know the ability to describe
the differences among colors to notice
the textures to examine the historical
precedents in rokoko style as opposed to
let's see what's new okhla core of
neoclassical style I I wish I could
grasp the history well enough because I
want to know not only the present nature
of these objects but the history of form
that contributed to them and why my best
priest priestess friend chose that form
as opposed to other forms yeah I would
like to be able to name why I find her
pocket Cornwall the embodiments of the
Gods nation tradition why I find them so
deeply beautiful but I don't find
everybody else's pocket Congo deeply
beautiful and I would like to understand
historically what I'm responding to in
the form that she gives to the gods yes
what is it about these sacred arts from
these are very different diverse regions
Nigeria Brazil the Caribbean
and Cuba yes and these are very valuable
Brazil Nigeria are my foes long yeah and
that when you look at sacred arts from
these different diverse places there's
different historical purposes for these
sacred arts through their lineages then
there's what the actual sacred art
itself is yes that's right and then the
way the ritual that they do with it and
then what is that unlocking what is that
unleashing with their spirit and then
what is it that the students that you
get to bring into that experience what
do they awaken to good oh thank you for
asking me that question okay so first of
all these traditions are united
historically by the fact of the Atlantic
slave trade from the late 15th century
until the year the the end of the last
third of the 19th century Western
Europeans traded in huge numbers of of
captive Africans bringing them to the
new world above all to produce sugar
more cheaply than free labor could have
produced it but also to produce cotton
and rice to generate enormous profits
not only for the European monarchies and
nation-states that tax the slave trade
but for the the planters in the Americas
who purchased those enslaved people and
drove them often to their deaths for the
benefit of the planters subsequently
free African Diaspora people traveled
back and forth between on the one hand
Cuba and Brazil on the other hand West
Africa and these populations interacted
with Europeans they interacted with
Native Americans and in each of these
places a religious formation came about
that combined their shared Western
African premises in different ways and
combined them with different European
traditions and combine them with
different Native American traditions and
in some cases combine them with
different Asian traditions be the Indian
tradition or Chinese tradition because
in different parts of western Africa and
the African Diaspora we interacted with
Chinese people and Indians as well or at
least Western images of Indians each of
these traditions makes a somewhat
different set of assumptions about the
world a somewhat different set of
assumptions about what kind of objects
best embody the forces that penetrate us
and overlap within us and each of them
is structured by a different kind of
Mythology so Brazilian Colombia is
highly structured by a hierarchy of
relative purity in imitation of what's
supposed to be an african original
haitian vodou is divided between largely
to ritual modalities one focused on
royalty that looks almost equally
African and European and one focused on
the adoration of and working with rebel
slaves spirits one set of spirits is
cool and and you can pray to them and
they'll more or less do what you ask if
you're patient enough the other spirits
are hot and fiery and angry and
defensive and are more likely to do
immediately what you ask as long and be
very effective at doing so the Cuban
tradition is similarly divided between
well much more let's see it dichotomize
--is West African traditions from West
Central African traditions represents
representing one as more royal more
divine more beneficent and one as
working with forces that are not as
beneficent ones more related to the dead
and ones more related more easier to
assign elements
of mercenary behavior so the could the
moral configurations in these places are
somewhat different yeah in West in West
African you're by religion there's an
emphasis on the difference between cool
gods and hot gods all of them can be
equally malevolent or beneficent they're
just forces in the universe they handled
properly respected properly they
generate good for us handled improperly
they can generate bad for us so there's
an emphasis on ballot in all of these
traditions its emphasis on balancing the
forces that are shaping us it did sound
very much like a yin and Yan exactly
yeah it's very very similar which is why
I one of the reasons that Chinese ritual
authorities and African ritual
authorities got along so well in China
and the Africans embraced Buddha the
Buddha and when yin and also on one goon
who's a god of the saint of the martial
arts in China and he has so on each of
these is an idiom of awakening an
inspiration about the wholeness of the
universe yeah but they named the
particular routes a bit differently yes
yes and alert us to different kinds of
connection in the world but I always
imagined that the thing that unites them
is the ocean yes yes there's a repeated
very important theme of the ocean and
it's and develop modalities and so I
always come back to the goddess yemaya
yemaya in the Cuban and Brazilian
tradition she's regarded as the goddess
of the sea in the Nigerian tradition
she's regarded it's the goddess of a
river but it's the river among all the
rivers in Nigeria that flows most
directly to the sea and her altars
contain a lot of marine seashells so the
ocean that unites us all is for me an
important touchstone and metaphor of of
the wholeness that leads polygamous
polygyny probably theistic traditions
presuppose
and so yeah it speaks to the wholeness
of the universe that you're very
concerned about - I love how within the
study of sacred arts from no matter
really where on the planet we study the
sacred arts thematically such a
similarity around the ocean around the
one and then whatever ways of archetypal
mythologically describing these forces
elements as powers it's just so gorgeous
the story that is being told about when
you notice yeah it seems to me that
Western Christian that the Abrahamic
religions focus much more on the sky
than the sea and one might also observe
that the Abrahamic religions are the
ones that have terrorized the rest of us
the most the the material logic of the
ocean is very different from the
material logic of our hierarchical
relationship with the sky one one tends
to be called the Father and one has to
be called a mother they're really
different logics and there is no
population of people more than
Christians and Muslims who have
classified and and Jewish people or
Hebrews will classified the gods of
other people as demons
it needed being wiped out and no
populations more than Christians and
Muslims have conquered land all over the
planet with the intention of dominating
those populations and eliminating their
gods which also includes regularly the
project of enslaving other people
murdering them and taking their land
based upon the fact that they worship
another set of gods and there has been
no greater victim of Abrahamic religions
in Africa so Africa has a special lesson
for us and the religions of the enslaved
have a special lesson for us about the
wrong way to pursue the one about the
very unkind results of monotheism Wow
what a very profound way to synthesize
what
is been happening here on our planet for
the longest time and for us to be able
to awaken to where we want to go in the
future
Asha Asha Amen yeah thank you very much
for joining us on the show everyone
would greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear our thoughts in the comments below
in the episode let us know your thinking
check out all the links in the bio below
to Randy's work check that out support
him please support the American
Anthropological Association as well you
find their links in the bio you can
support us as well in the show and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see blood something Randy's clogged
if your institution might be interested
in hosting the spirit the exhibition
called spirited things sacred arts of
the black Atlantic which I have curated
to illustrate some of these points
please contact international arts and
artists in Washington DC and they can
arrange to have the exhibition visit
your institution
[Music]